every time you come here we see you
eating something completely different
than every other person that I see
walking down the street what were you
reading on the bus right over here it
was spiritual advice from great elders
great Russian elders its 20th century we
have a couple newcomers to the u.s.
women's chess seen here we've got
Victorian knee and Alena cats have he
played them before and what do you know
about them I actually haven't played
them before so I don't I'm not as well
acquainted we found the band with the
other players
does it get harder and harder each year
to come up with new ideas against the
same women because you seem to play each
other every year this solid group of
eight women that are here all generally
you know I've done pretty well so you
know I need to keep coming up with new
ideas all the work so you think it's
their responsibility to surprise you
well that is true but it's also my
responsibility to prepare awhile and
choose my openings while and everything
so now I'm not saying that I'm not doing
any you know preparation but I'm just
saying that it's not like you know my
problem is finding new ideas against
them have you had any tournament
successes recently that have given you
some confidence coming into this
tournament no I've had you know I would
say the opposite you know tournament
unsuccessful you know so maybe you're
due for a good result oh that's possible
I'm definitely here to do my best you
know we're gonna see with what that
means do you like a larger feel do you
like to ten person field instead of
eight I thought last year's format was
interesting I was actually pretty happy
they were experimenting with it to make
it more interesting like that I didn't
work out so well for me personally but I
still thought the format was pretty good
and maybe they could have tweaked it a
little bit maybe you need like some
small improvements overall I thought it
was interesting you know and now we're
back to sort of the standard round robin
which it's fine for me I don't think
it's the most exciting format you know
the spectators you think that the
organizers do a good job of good even
putting on a good event here in st.
Louis I feel like they respect the
players they respect the game you know
and they do everything possible for us
to do our best here well thanks very
much for your time Irena good luck on
getting your fourth US Women's thank you